a group of heavily armed Muslim
extremists are now in custody in New
Mexico officials saying there are that
five adults including the two men you
see on your screen are facing child
abuse charges after authorities
discovered they were hiding 11 children
children between the ages of 1 and 15 in
a remote compound the local sheriff
describes it as the saddest living
conditions in poverty he's ever seen
with the kids having only dirty rags for
clothing amid other horrifying details
they were starving joining us now with
more is Monique Jacobson happiness
Secretary for New Mexico's children
youth and families Department Monique I
read this this morning I just it took my
breath away tell us what you know so
it's certainly heartbreaking the
children are in our custody now and you
know our focus has been and will
continue to be really the safety and
well-being of these children what do
they look like so you know we can't ever
really talk specifically about about the
actual net worth in the business case
well there's just their condition I mean
it was written about that they were
starved that they were they were
deprived of water basic sanitation no
education you can't confirm or deny into
these details I think the American
people want to know about this it's that
horrific certainly so I can tell you
that what we do in a situation like this
the very first thing that we do is is
really make sure that we can get those
most basic needs met so ensure that
we're getting the children food water
that we get them cleaned up and
comfortable clothing and then of course
we have a lot of other assessments that
need to occur medical assessments you
know making sure that we are doing
forensic interviews so we can understand
exactly what they know and what's gone
on in their in their living conditions
so we've been working you know around
the clock to get all of this done and
again really focusing on what we can do
to decrease the trauma that these
children may have experienced I mean you
can't some of the
where we understand that related to them
parents but it's not clear who they are
where some of them were mothers that
allowed to live in this condition
condition and the child that they were
looking for has been abducted by one of
the parents correct that's that's my
understanding yes that that's how they
ended up coming to that site but they
never they've never been hasn't been
found yet correct that's correct that's
not one of the children that that we
have in our custody right are any of the
children saying anything about you know
you know why why this happened to them
especially the older children did they
give you any insights yet so no you know
again in a situation like this we really
we work with trained forensic
interviewers who are again trained in
how to talk to to children and really
get them to open up but we do know
oftentimes it will take a good deal of
time before children are comfortable
enough that that they will talk to us
about what all they have experienced in
their life up till now and do you have
any idea how long they've been held in
these conditions those are all the kinds
of questions that we're working to
gather information on as as we speak all
right well we got to get more
information on this because my viewers
want to know and I know people all
across the country are trying to figure
out how this happened who these
abductors were and what if any sicko
motivation including religious
motivation there could have been